Narrator: The second
episode of the final season
of "Game of Thrones" was full
of long-awaited reunions,
references to seasons past,
and clues about the
battle that lies ahead.
Here are 14 details you might've missed.
And, of course, warning:
Spoilers are coming.
The North is in full
battle-preparation mode,
and the slight changes in the
opening credits reflect that,
showing new trenches lining
the borders of Winterfell.
The episode opens on Jaime,
who's found himself on trial
by Daenerys and the Starks.
He must answer for the
murder of Dany's father,
King Aerys II, as well as for his role
in Ned Stark's untimely death.
When Daenerys demands that Jaime explain
why he deserted Cersei, he responds,
"Because this goes beyond
loyalty. This is about survival."
His words echo Brienne's
in the season seven finale.
Brienne: Oh f--- loyalty!
Jaime: F--- loyalty?
Brienne: This goes beyond
houses, and honor, and oaths.
Narrator: When Tyrion throws
his weight behind Jaime,
Daenerys does not react kindly,
saying, "Perhaps Jaime
trusts his little brother
to defend him right up until
the moment he slits my throat."
Her wording beckons back to the prophecy
the woods witch told
young Cersei in the books:
"The valonqar shall wrap
his hands about your pale,
white throat, and choke
the life from you."
"Valonqar" means "little
brother" in Valyrian,
which is why Cersei always believed Tyrion
would be the one to kill her.
The show left out this
part of the prophecy,
so we can't be sure Tyrion will play
any significant role in Cersei's death.
When it's decided that
Jaime can join their ranks,
Grey Worm begrudgingly returns his sword,
known as Widow's Wail.
Olenna: What did he call it?
Jaime: Widow's Wail.
Narrator: It's one of the two blades
that the Lannisters forged
after melting down Ice,
the ancestral sword of House Stark.
Its sister sword is Oathkeeper,
which Jaime bestowed upon Brienne.
Now, with Jaime serving
under Brienne's command,
the two blades of Ice have been reunited
for the first time since Ned
left Winterfell in season one.
At the exact moment that Jaime is rearmed,
we hear a familiar musical cue.
The song is Jaime's theme, first played
when he recounts to
Brienne the real reason
he killed Aerys Targaryen.
Jaime: Would you've kept your oath then?
Narrator: And again when he was headed
to Riverrun to break
the Blackfish's siege.
There are new as well as old weapons,
as Arya checks in with
Gendry about the new spear
she asked him to make.
From her sketches, it looks
like this is the design
that the show's weapons
master, Tommy Dunne,
spoke of in a recent
interview with Vanity Fair.
He said, "There is one
creation in season eight
that is absolutely phenomenal...
in that it's able to be reverse-engineered
and made into two different items."
If that's true, this double-ended tool
will prove handy when it's time for Arya
to face down White Walkers
or cross a few more
people off her kill list.
The flirtation scene
between Arya and Gendry
visually mirrors one of
their past interactions
in season two.
During the Lannister brother reunion,
Tyrion repeats his tried-and-true joke
from all the way back to season one.
Shagga: How would you like
to die Tyrion, son of Tywin?
Tyrion: In my own bed at the age of 80
with a belly full of wine
and a girl's mouth around my c---.
Narrator: Then Tyrion
half-jokes that maybe
he'll still get his last
shot at murdering Cersei,
saying, "Maybe after I'm
dead, I'll march down
to King's Landing and rip her apart."
It sounds lighthearted,
but really this could be
a grim foreshadowing of
Tyrion and many others
being reanimated as Wights.
After the meeting to discuss tactics,
Jon stands with his former brothers,
Samwell and Edd, the
latter of whom announces,
"And now our watch begins."
It's a return to the oath
of the brotherhood...
Jon and Sam: Night gathers,
and now my watch begins.
Narrator: After Jon
announced that his watch
had ended, back in season six.
Jon: My watch is ended.
Narrator: Now the brothers must again
take on the burden of defending the realm.
Next, there's a doomsday romance scene
between Arya and Gendry.
He confides in her that
he's Robert's bastard
and the last of the Baratheons.
It's a direct reversal of
the scene in season three
when Arya revealed to him
her true identity as a Stark.
Arya: It's Arya of House Stark.
Narrator: Their physical union
echoes Robert's and Ned's
proposed union of their houses
underneath the crypts of
Winterfell in season one.
Robert: I have a son. You have a daughter.
We'll join our houses.
Narrator: When they undress,
Arya reveals some grisly scars,
the result of stab wounds inflicted on her
by the Waif in season six.
Meanwhile, in front of
Winterfell's fireplace,
Jaime holds a spontaneous
knighting ceremony
for Brienne on the eve of
her biggest battle yet.
She's proclaimed the Knight
of the Seven Kingdoms,
which is the title of this episode.
It's also the name of a trio of novellas
written by George R.R. Martin
as a spinoff from the "Song
of Ice and Fire" series.
The books follow a chivalrous knight
known as Ser Duncan the Tall
who's actually mentioned
several times in the show.
Old Nan: I could tell you
about Ser Duncan the Tall.
Narrator: At a 2016 fan convention,
Martin confirmed that Brienne
was descended from Ser Duncan.
We can guess that's where
she got her unusual height
and her bravery.
After Brienne's induction
into the knighthood,
Podrick performs "Jenny of Oldstones,"
his own impressive rendition of a song
from the original "Song
of Ice and Fire" books.
The song references Jenny of Oldstones,
a character from the books
who was married to
Prince Duncan Targaryen.
♪ Jenny would dance with her ghost ♪
This version of the song
included new lyrics,
and the episode's closing credits
even debuted a cover of the song
performed by Florence and the Machine.
♪ High in the halls ♪
♪ of the kings who are gone ♪
Podrick's singing is
paired with the montage
showing the people of Winterfell
making their final preparations.
The music and visuals evoke this scene
from "Return of the King"
set to the sad tune of Pippin's
song, "The Edge of Night."
♪ To the edge of night ♪
The similar mood makes sense,
especially given that the director
of the impending battle scene
cited "Lord of the
Rings" as an inspiration.
One thing is for sure, the episode ends
on a decidedly ominous note.
So there you have it.
Did we miss anything?
Let us know in the comments.